because I know your kind I don't want to
say you're into conspiracy theories but
you're into looking at not just
accepting things your let you kind of
see the bigger picture don't handle a
position of power well yeah I'm a good
example of it everybody hits you you
know it's not something human beings are
good at
generally speaking some people every
once in a while you get like a sink that
is but like no I think you know either
it's absolute chaos out there or I think
that the reason why they're the richest
people are concerned about what they're
doing to the environment is because
they're going to replace us with robots
is what I think I know sounds knocking
nuts but I don't they gonna replace us
and then they're gonna live and then
there's gonna be a group of us where a
job is gonna be to reproduce so they
have organs that they can harvest and
you to God be sure this is a Matt Damon
sci-fi movie at some point look I Robot
you know saying I'm right I'm just
saying like it's a possibility just look
at like well if you look at the [ __ ]
that corporations do yeah yeah you know
to the drinking water and in prolonging
Wars and in in and all the [ __ ] that
they [ __ ] do you know getting these
guys bought and paid for all these
[ __ ] guys have been president they
all come out they worth like eight and
bama's won't they eighty million the
Clintons with hundreds of millions on
bushes and worth I say how do you do
that you're in public service you made
you made five hundred grand a year at
the highest paid level as a president
for eight years that's four million
bucks I don't know you know if you
didn't pay taxes yeah how do you mind
you get that thing to multiply by 4 to 8
and then well like do these speaking
engagements and sorts of people who
[ __ ] put them in office it's like
they're watching the frat boy don't even
try to hide it
yeah so so I imagine you don't have an
Amazon Alexa in your house what is that
oh that's that lady though you talk to
it makes you dumber records all your
[ __ ] yeah you're never gonna be able to
run for president there's many reasons
why I can but yeah you ever go into so
what that thing's gonna do is just
totally record everything that you say
hmm everything that you say in your
house okay and then then they're just
gonna have key words
yeah they'll type in the n-word Dobby oh
they'll type in whatever the [ __ ] you
said whatever I don't know what you say
at home
I don't know
well Alexis will ya don't have anything
and they'll just string it together they
don't have enough you'll say it if said
enough [ __ ] right he's exactly right
they'll know it together Howard Stern
does it what's that it takes like sound
bites and strings them together to make
you know yeah I mean like there there's
no reason why yeah if there was one hey
that's that's what they're going to
there was one case where I got actually
solved a murder because the person who
got killed had an Alexa and it like and
it recorded the murder so they went in
they got the recording you even though
you're like huh that's not recording
turns out oh yeah yes it is it one of
those [ __ ] people who makes the
flat-screen TVs got busted they were
watching you on the camera watching TV
no what if you're banging your wife what
are they doing and the fact that it's
just in the fact that you know if one
person gets your address and everybody
gets your address and they're selling
your private information with all the
stalkers and psychos out there like yeah
but like they put politicians in office
so they don't get in trouble for all the
horrible [ __ ] that they're doing which
is why I think robots yeah they'll take
over and they'll harvest our organs it
all makes sense
well the first time I fact I got to kick
with you which was awesome was the Big
Papi roast and I want to hear and maybe
Brad can you can enlighten him on your
experience with that because one thing I
found incredible was the amount of like
lack of prep you seemed to like display
and then just destroyed as usual and you
went up last but you did something that
I've never seen before were you like you
[ __ ] on the the organization that put on
the event you know in a fun jokey way
but still like was taking shots it was
like videotaping the whole time idea
rock was gonna get in trouble yeah what
are they doing because this is Aaron
it's gotta get taken out of Carnot it
was some guy with the cell phone right
that's why I told her to shut that off
oh yeah yeah yeah cuz it's a roast and
you take one thing and it's like Gronk
said horrible things like yeah it's a
roast yeah but then it goes on those
clickbait sites right and then they act
like it's and it seems he was like grant
talks about blacks Jews and Dominicans
it was like everybody did yeah that's a
roast did you have fun with that was
that here a great time yeah maybe I I
think I made fun of Lenny Clarke more
than I made fun
I was sitting to go I don't make fun of
big papi that guy like you know yeah I
was gonna ask because that's I mean
those are your guys right oh you know
you said yes make fun of him for being a
[ __ ] D H it's another [ __ ] what's it
like to play pro baseball that's a lot
like what waiting for a bus once every
40 minutes you get up and you groundout
into the shift yeah yeah yeah made fun
of his big [ __ ] square head and yeah
but he was so [ __ ] cool he was cool I
just member he just kept yelling [ __ ]
you with me I was going [ __ ] you too you
wanted to get roasted it was just the
most fun he was such a fun guy it was so
great and I thought Pedroia was great
unbelievable the petroi went up he's
like I don't like you [ __ ] [ __ ] I
wrote these jokes or whatever I love
that it's like there it is yeah this
spark that's why he's a champion yeah
yeah I liked you know I I I thought the
whole thing was you enjoyed the process
of even just like writing jokes for
something specific like that well yeah
you know something I've avoided doing a
lot of roasts just because I learned
early on someone always ends up getting
mad and then so there's got to be like I
have to have some sort of connection to
the person that I'm roasting right right
just go in there is a hired gun it's
guaranteed you get a piss somebody yeah
you get some of those relationship yeah
it just got to the point where was it
was getting like like the whole like
we're roasting you because we love you
was just gone yes just like hey I heard
your mother died to AIDS
let's you know let's find your corpse
and [ __ ] jizz on it yeah it's like
when they bring in Coulter to the roast
it's like yeah there's so that's the
other thing too yeah where they bring
the personal trumpet I think became
president anytime there's a roast mm-hmm
the problem is okay we're gonna roast
Adam right there's only so many angles
we all know him in the same [ __ ] way
notice or Alexis sure Alexis could do
[ __ ] tomorrow so you have to have
that other person that gets invited
right who's always excited that they
were invited but don't realize the
reason why they were invited right is
because it's gonna be open season on
yeah and I horn you love the at the
Pamela Anderson roast yeah the situation
from Jersey Shore yeah carrot-top got a
bad one
yeah and it was like it was just like
and Donald Trump got invited to that
Obama thing and if you notice as far as
I mean obviously wasn't there but it
looked like they sat him right in the
middle of the [ __ ] room so that Seth
Meyers could find it baby was perfectly
lit like was a layup and I think that he
was he was so [ __ ] mad he didn't even
know he ran for prime was so [ __ ] up
since then like I don't know when that
was but like within four years of that
he's walking into Obama's house like see
you later I mean it was I was like a
[ __ ] it was like the end of Empire
Strikes Back
Peter was just like wow man I can't wait
to see the next one this yeah so yeah
there's always that with those rows so
mm-hmm I just thought you know I loved I
loved her in that whole time too because
when we were working on her jokes at
laughs Boston and you know in and you
had kind of heard that I was gonna dress
up as an old Yankee fan and you were
like I love that you were like what are
gonna dress up like Babe Ruth or some
[ __ ] like here so bust my balls and then
you had no clue I'd flown it like a
makeup lady and was transforming myself
I saw you in the lobby I didn't
recognize well that's why I've told that
story so many times because I was a
member I went up to you I don't remember
exactly what was said but I was like hey
boy I'm a big fan and you're like all
right buddy yeah thank you so much you
were nice and then I go hey I got I got
some notes for your cartoon you're like
what and I was like yeah man if you
don't mind I get to speak everything in
your buddy [ __ ] off it's like come on
man and I go bill it's me and you go
what and you're look when you realize it
was me was like what happened to your
neck yeah it looked like you know those
people you can see that they have like
[ __ ] was it hypertension yeah like this
person's gonna have a heart attack like
that's what your neck look like it's
just like this guy yeah it's a lot of
salty food it was amazing and they went
I love to was was how much the Red Sox
fans they loved it yeah that's what a
sports town Boston is that you came out
as a Yankee fan they booted first and
then you like go [ __ ] yourself we got 27
and then they laugh yeah they left that
was that was cool yeah yeah I thought
that was really cool in their part
because I thought they were gonna be you
know possibly getting you know upset
about would you ever do something like
that like not only for a roast but
specifically but like an acting job like
do you ever see a part or or envision
like man at some point I'd love to just
get in full like you know like the way
Jim Carrey did the Grinch like somebody
that intense eddie murphy until you
do Greendale you watch the entertainment
and you see how long they're sitting in
that chair yeah the straws up their nose
yeah like that's really for an actor
yeah I like PETA movies is [ __ ] cool
yeah I like acting I really enjoy it but
I don't want to have to [ __ ] dress up
like the werewolf everyday or you know
these personal trainers and [ __ ] so you
can play you know [ __ ] so you worn it
yeah yeah so you're not gonna like play
a superhero where you get a six-pack
look well I don't think at this age I
think I got a way I look I got a better
chance playing Lex Luthor I think so but
I like I like the parts that I've been
getting out here and I'm very
comfortable well I don't think at this
age I think I got that way I look I got
a better chance playing Lex Luthor well
so but I like I like the parts that I've
been getting out here and I'm very
comfortable with it and I still love via
comedian and that's what I liked it like
there's no more fun than doing that like
I just played two of my favorite cities
I was in Minneapolis and I was in
Detroit and I love all that Cleveland